a Sinister laugh pierces The Silence of
the African Savannah soon joined by the
sounds of Flesh tearing and Bones being
pulverized haunting arched back
creatures Dart around their meal ripping
it apart with their enormous Jaws in
just 25 minutes an entire zebra is
devoured skin Hooves bones teeth and all
only a pool of blood
Remains the spotted hyena is the most
numerous large predator in Africa with
an estimated 27,000 to 47,000
individuals living in the wild their
habitat includes all types of
environments such as forests swamps
mountains and deserts and their
reputation among humans wherever they
may be is largely negative they're often
seen as ugly cowardly and gluttonous
the evil cronies who helped scar kill
Mufasa the Shady llies who lurk in the
shadows waiting for an opportunity to
steal a more noble animals meal their
cackling is unsettling and their large
teeth punched over figure and darting
movements are menacing but hyenas are so
much more than just creepy they are
remarkably intelligent and extremely
effective Hunters largely because they
don't operate
alone they live in clans of six to over
100 individuals larger than any Wolfpack
lion pride or orcapod and these
groupings aren't just a bunch of
individuals who happen to coexist near
each other these Clans are incredibly
sophisticated and their social structure
is unlike that of any other carnivore
but sophisticated doesn't mean Pleasant
the lives of spotted hyenas are filled
with brutal and constant competition
with other members of their Clan to even
get a chance at eating a meal a spotted
hyena must prove its dominance over the
others again and again and for the males
this is even more difficult because
females always dominate them and while a
matriarchal group of animals is not
unheard of it gets even weirder female
hyenas are not just in charge they've
also evolved so that their genitals look
almost exactly like male genitalia they
urinate mate and even give birth through
this pseudo penis why do hyenas live in
such big groups when these groups are
filled with constant fighting why are
the females in charge and why did their
reproductive organs evolve to be
indistinguishable from a
males of the four species of hyena the
spotted or laughing hyena is the largest
and while most people compare hyenas to
dogs they actually have more in common
genetically with cats and are even more
closely related to mongooses and civits
and the size of a spotted hyena might
surprise you they are not the scraggly
little muts Disney makes them out to be
they're actually as large or larger than
wolves weighing up to 86 kg or 190 lb
and reaching 1.8 m in length and for its
size the spotted hyena has one of the
strongest skulls of any carnivore hyid
are the only existing animal who evolved
to crack bones with their jaws and
spotted hyenas are the top among them
their bite can exert a pressure of 80 kg
Force per square cm or
1,140 PSI which is 40% more Force than a
lion can generate and 15% more than a
grizzly bear wild hyenas have even been
seen cracking open giraffe femur which
measure 7 cm in diameter the teeth of a
spotted hyena are built exactly for this
the upper and lower third Prem molers
are enormous conical bone Crushers
compare this to an African lion it's a
voracious Predator but does not have the
bone crushing molers that a hyena does
in addition to this the spotted hyena
has a pronounced sagittal Crest to which
extremely strong jaw muscles are
attached this bone cracking ability
allows them to take advantage of a food
source that is inaccessible to most
animals but they weren't always so
formidable before the spotted hyena
diverged from the striped and brown
hyenas 10 million years ago its direct
ancestor would have been a smaller
scavenger type hyena that could maybe
Crush some bones but not take down
massive prey but at one point in their
evolution spotted hyenas developed sharp
caracals behind their crushing premolar
teeth that cut through tough skin like
scissors these teeth becoming bigger and
sharper meant the hyenas no longer had
to wait for their prey to die to eat it
as is the case with solitary scavengers
like the brown hyena they had evolved to
become social Hunters unlike other types
of hyenas spotted hyenas kill about 95%
of their food themselves scientists have
ranked their hunting abilities on par
with that of lions and cheetahs their
large bodies likely evolved as a result
of the transition from Scavenging to
hunting scavenger hyenas tend to be
smaller to use less energy while
covering great distances in order to
find a meal whereas social Hunters need
to be bigger to take down large prey but
that's not to say hyenas can't travel
great distances and travel fast they
extra long front legs let them run at
speeds up to 60
kmph chasing down prey for sometimes
kilomet at a time the size of their prey
depends on if they're hunting alone or
in a group while solo they'll go after
smaller animals like birds rabbits
porcupines and fish as their numbers
grow they choose bigger and bigger pre
from gazel and warthogs to Buffalo and
even young rhinos once they catch their
meal spotted hyenas give out their
characteristic laugh to alert their Clan
and the feasting begins within minutes
entire animals are consumed and although
they are primarily Hunters hyenas don't
discriminate when it comes to their food
source they've been seen eating bugs
like termites and caterpillars and also
rotting putrid flesh that other animals
refuse to eat and yet they don't even
get sick from it they happily eat
Anthrax infected carcasses and are
unaffected by infectious disease
outbreaks like rabies and distemper
which have killed many lions and wild
dogs one way they fight off these
potentially deadly microbes is by having
an incredibly acidic stomach herbivores
who don't eat risky meat have a stomach
pH of 4 to 6 many carnivores who try to
stick to fresh meat have a stomach pH of
3.6 and a hyena stomach pH is less than
two this High concentration of
hydrochloric acid decimates most
bacteria before it can do any damage
hyenas also have a relatively short
digestive tract which prevents bacteria
from lingering too long hyenas also
likely pass small doses of pathogens
around as they groom eat and compete
with each other which may help build up
group-wide immunity to toxins like
Anthrax and on top of this they have
naturally high levels of
antibodies but not all spotted hyenas
have the same amount the higher the
social status a spotted hyena has the
more antibodies they carry such hyenas
are better fed and spend less energy on
hunting and nursing injuries lower
ranked hyenas do not get such luxuries
and it's not just antibody levels that
are at stake when it comes to the social
order of hyenas in a hyena Clan
everything comes down to
rank spotted hyena Clans have the most
rigid hierarchy structure of any social
mammal and it really pays to be on top
in addition to Better Health a higher
rank means more food stronger allies and
the right to reproduce and in a clan of
spotted hyenas females are always in
charge physically female spotted hyenas
are larger than males by as much as 20
kg they're also stronger and arguably
meaner at the top of the group is the
alpha female when she has Cubs they're
ranked right beneath her and as they
grow up their cubs are ranked beneath
them and so on daughters usually remain
in their birth Clan For Life and build
close relationships with their mothers
and sisters one grouping of of mothers
and daughters is known as a matrilineal
group separate matrilineal groups often
join together creating one massive Clan
these kin groups are organized within
the clan by the dominance level of their
oldest female but unfortunately for
males their place is always at the
bottom the life of a male hyena may
start out okay if he's born to a high
ranking female but this is shortlived
males are only allowed to stay with
their families for around 2 to 3 years
after that they leave the clan they're
born into and beg for admittance into a
new one if accepted they will rank
absolute last after all females and
their cubs and after other males who
joined the clan before them they are
known as immigrant males and their life
basically sucks they're forced to live
on the outskirts are the last to eat if
there's even anything left
and have absolutely no say in when or
with who they get to mate they are
generally riddled with injuries have
worn down teeth from chewing on too many
bones and live half as long as females
while the life of a female isn't nearly
as Bleak it's endlessly competitive
while males are known appeasers during
conflict to avoid losing what little
status they have females are much more
aggressive and are constantly picking
fights to gain or keep their rank Clans
are usually stable for many years but if
any of the top ranking females die peace
is no longer guaranteed a coalition of
the lower ranking females May topple the
alpha female Coalition from the throne
females will even kill each other's Cubs
to maintain their social standing and to
cut their Rivals Bloodlines short in one
study that looked at deaths of cubs
under Oney old 21 out of 99 of them
could be attributed to infanticide
Always by female Killers many times the
killer was even related to the Cubs she
murdered even litter mates have to
compete sometimes to the death most
litters have two Cubs which fight for
the right to nurse first Sometimes one
Cub will end up killing their weaker
sibling half of young hyenas die before
reaching maturity so why do hyenas
bother living together if there's so
much risk because whether they like it
or not they need each other because
while the risk from hyenas within their
own Clan is high the risk from other
clans of hyenas or Prides of lions is
even higher they need each other to
defend themselves and their kills and to
take down large prey and those immigrant
males who all the females seem to hate
they too are recruited to help with
hunting or fighting and these hyena
Clans however dysfunctional are
extremely effective they've been
observed defending territories of up to
620 square mil or, 1600 square km from
outside threats a single hyena could not
defeat a lion but a clan of hyenas
absolutely can hyenas are the only thing
lions are regularly seen running from
but as soon as the prey is killed or
outside threat is nullified hyenas
within the same Clan do try to keep
their distance from one another to
reduce the chances of
Confrontation this Arrangement is known
as a fishion fusion Society individuals
come together when needed and then
disperse as soon as possible and
maintaining this Arrangement requires
sophisticated communication skills
spotted hyenas have one of the richest
vocal repertoar of any terrestrial
mammal their laugh sounds Sinister but
is actually a sign of excitement fear or
frustration and their whooping call
conveys a wealth of information to their
clanmates it's a haunting sound that can
travel up to 3 miles transporting with
it information about the color including
its identity sex and age hyenas can even
count how many calls they are hearing a
useful tool when trying to gauge whether
to fight a rival gang
hyenas live and die by the clan a clan
ruled by females a clan whose
cooperation breeds competition but
there's one more thing about spotted
hyenas that's just downright strange the
reproductive organs of a female spotted
hyena look almost exactly like a male's
and scientists don't really know
why the reproductive organs of female
spotted hyenas are unlike any other
animal even other hyena species they
have an unusually long clitoris
resembling a penis it's been classified
as a pseudo penis or peniform clitoris
and is used to urinate mate and give
birth they also have a fused and
enlarged labia resembling a scrotum this
atypical Anatomy has caused researchers
to misgender female spotted hyenas as
male only to discover the truth when
they've later given birth this unusual
Anatomy means they're the only mammal to
lack a vaginal opening which makes
mating and birthing very difficult to
mate a female retracts the pseudo penis
in on itself kind of like pushing up the
sleeve on your shirt and creates an
opening into which the male inserts his
own penis and while this may be
difficult there's one benefit that's
clear it gives the female hyenas
complete control over who they mate with
because penetration is impossible
without their cooperation but even when
mating does occur the chances of
successful reproduction is low Hyena's
reproductive Canal is twice as long as a
similarly sized animals and includes a
hair pin turn making it an incredible
difficult Journey for sperm traveling to
the uterus and and for Cubs during birth
for first time mothers living in
captivity about 60% of their cubs die
most often from Suffocation while
getting stuck in the birth canal these
challenges have made scientists wonder
why spotted highas have evolved in this
way since reproduction is essential for
survival of the species why has their
Anatomy developed in such a way that
makes it so difficult it all comes back
to competition there their large skulls
jaws and teeth are what makes spotted
hyenas able to crush bones which lets
them outperform other Predators but
growing these features takes several
years so in order for young hyenas to
survive long enough to develop them
hyena mothers nurse their cubs for
around 14 months and help them get
enough food even after they're weaned
until they're three or four this means
it's in the interest of the species for
birth rates to be lower than other types
of Predator why extra babies have to die
in the birth canal or fight each other
to the death instead of simply not being
conceived in the first place I don't
know the theme of hyena life seems to be
brutality at every turn but as ruthless
as it all seems so much of what hyenas
are fighting for is to keep their cubs
alive hyenas are very caring mothers
when their cubs die they are distraught
and they do everything in their power to
protect them and keep them safe the
reputation of hyenas as creepy selfish
scavengers is largely misplaced while
their lives are Rife with hardship and
competition their capacity for
cooperation is unrivaled in the world of
predators and their place among the
predators of Africa is not lowly behind
the Cheetahs leopards and lions if
anything clans of hyenas are the top
among them all no one knows spotted
hyenas better than the people who study
them in the field and of them no one is
more well-versed than expert biologist
and animal behaviorist K whole Camp I
was lucky enough to snag an interview
with her to get the inside story about
what it's like to study these amazing
creatures in the wild and our main
research tools are a pair of binoculars
and a notebook we can watch them from
about this far away it's just a blast
being in the field with spotted hyenas
for so long Dr Hull Camp has seen a huge
array of personalties ities and it's
impossible to not form attachments to
certain individuals my favorite hyena of
all time was a hyena named cois and she
was really curious a very smart hyena
and she figured out that she could go
catch a gazelle and she could do it in
the presence of all these other hyenas
and then she would bring it right over
and put it right down next to the tire
but nobody else would come that close to
the car and she figured this out right
away but life in the bush is dangerous
you know she I saw her get bitten in the
face by a big Cobra once he had two
puncture wounds on either side of her
nose nose and they started welling up
blood and I thought oh no you know she's
going to die now and she staggered off
into the bushes and I didn't ever expect
to see her again but a couple days later
she comes out of their bushes and she's
looking just fine so her stories about
how these animals defy death at every
turn are incredible and she explains
what humans stand to learn from their
near invincibility but working in the
field is no Cakewalk either and hearing
her stories about the dangers she and
her team face spending months the field
in Kenya are riveting and most of all I
love doing interviews like this to learn
what it's actually like to do the
research that I talk about here on
YouTube for everyone who dreams of one
day being a biologist interviews like
these with Dr hul Camp shine a light on
the wild adventure that such a career
entails to watch the full unedited
interview head over to nebula and find
it under the real science field notes
page nebula is a streaming platform that
we built for exactly this reason to
explore topics more deeply sometimes in
new formats like this interview nebula
allows me to take risks like this and
experiment more whether it's this
extended interview or the nebula
original series I made called becoming
human about the incredible story of how
we came to understand human evolution
nebula is a place for all of its
creators to make experimental and new
content like Joe Scott's Mysteries of
the human body which takes you through
some of the the most baffling diseases
and epidemics from history or Wendover
Productions extremities which shows you
why and how people live in Earth's most
isolated and extreme settlements nebula
has even produced a featurelength film
called night of the coconut and a genre
bending award-winning play called the
prince which you can watch in its
entirety on nebula and now if you sign
up with the link below subscribers also
get access to classes you can watch
dozens of in-depth classes of creators
teaching you how to create so if you
sign up using the link below you can
support this channel directly and get
both nebula and nebula classes for 40%
off the annual plan for just $30 for the
entire
year